[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
ad matin du sénat les missions qui vous
fait vivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée et on va parler d'europe ce
matin et du rôle de l'union européenne
pour sortir de la crise sanitaire et
économique
le président emmanuel macron évoqué hier
la nécessité d'une indépendance
européenne notamment dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique il a défendu le plan de
relance européen à l'initiative de la
france et de l'allemagne
et pour parler de ce rôle de l'union
européenne les sénateurs ont organisé
jeudi dernier un débat avec amélie de
montchalin secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes je vous laisse
écouter ce débat merci d'avoir accepté
de nous rejoindre nous nous réunissons
ce matin pour le traditionnel débat
préalable au conseil qui se tiendra dans
huit jours par visioconférence à
l'occasion du précédent conseil européen
fin avril nous étions encore en période
de confinement et nous vous enviez
entendu madame la ministre par téléphone
avec quelques difficultés techniques
dont je vous prie encore de nous excuser
aussi je me réjouis aujourd'hui que nous
soyons réunis physiquement au sénat et
je tiens à vous remercier d'avoir bien
voulu nous vous déplacer je n'oublie pas
que d'autres collègues sont également
connectés pour participer à distance à
cette réunion et je souhaite à tous la
bienvenue et on commence à les voir je
dirais individuellement sur l'écran le
conseil européen du 19 juin s'annonce
une nouvelle fois comme un jalon
important de l'histoire de l'union
européenne
celle ci traverse une crise inédite
sanitaires mais aussi économique et
bientôt sociale qui appelle une réponse
que je qualifierais d'inédites cette
réponse est construit progressivement au
fil des dernières semaines la banque
centrale européenne s'est mobilisée la
première elle est désormais engagée dans
un programme de rachat de dette
souveraine
en réponse à la pandémie qui s'élève à
1350 milliards d'euros l'union
européenne a ensuite construit une
réponse économique à hauteur de 540
milliards à trois volets le mécanisme
européen de stabilité le m us chacun le
connais l'instrument su
on est super heureux c'est un peu moins
connus d'un instrument qui a pour but de
soutenir les régimes nationaux de
chômage partiel et ensuite un fonds de
garantie de la banque européenne
d'investissement l'abbaye
mais lors de sa dernière réunion le 23
avril le conseil européen a également
décidé le principe de la création d'un
instrument spécifique de relance de
l'économie européenne à mois plus tard
s'inspirant d'une initiative
franco-allemande que nous allons la
commission européenne proposait un
nouveau schéma qui repose sur un nouveau
projet de cadre financier pluriannuel
pour l'union augmenté d'un effort
financier substantiel
je souligne le mot puisqu'il s'agit de
750 milliards d'euros dédiés à la
relance l'intégration dans le cadre
financier pluriannuel de ce plan destiné
à rendre l'europe plus verte numérique
plus judith halle et résiliente est en
soi une bonne nouvelle pour la
construction européenne
car la solidarité communautaire devient
ainsi le socle du plan de relance
elle soulève toutefois des questions
complexes et exigent du conseil européen
qu'il examinera le 19 juin de s'entendre
en même temps sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel et son plan de relance
c'est un énorme défi surtout dans un
contexte où quatre états dits frugaux
ont déjà marqué leur résistance le sénat
tient à se positionner en amont de cette
réunion
c'est pourquoi la commission des
affaires européennes a adopté hier une
proposition de résolution sur ce sujet
que la commission des finances examinera
mardi ce texte salue la proposition de
la commission
sa structure son ampleur ces objectifs
tout en esters tout en insistant sur
quelques impératifs
j'avoue que quelques glissements
notamment au travers de l' enveloppe de
190 milliards de ce plan de relance sur
le cfp est assez je dirais original et
astucieuse pour être clair dans le cfp
que je qualifierais de soc
nous réaffirmons l'importance de la
souveraineté alimentaire et donc la
priorité accordée au premier pilier de
la pac
dont la commission entend raboter les
crédits par rapport au cfp actuelle nous
nous inquiétons aussi de voir émerger
une conception du verdissement de la pac
qui pourrait conduire si nous n'y
prenions garde et sachez que le cnl
dessus va être parti en attentif à la
décroissance avec 10 % de surface
agricole utile en moi entre autres et et
j'avoue qu'il faudra comptabiliser tous
les efforts qui ont été faits par la
france en la matière depuis des
décennies parce que nous avons la
fâcheuse tendance dans ce pays
ah je dirais faire du verdissement plus
plus plus quand nos autres partenaires
s'en tiennent simplement aux
orientations
je dirais de la commission nous
insistons aussi sur la nécessité de
renforcer quelques lignes budgétaires
essentiels pour l'autonomie européenne
le fonds européen de défense est là
ladislas poniatowski remplaçant le
prénom cambon insistera là dessus il
n'est pas convenable qu'à chaque fois
dire à deux reprises le fonds européen
de défense deviennent des variables
d'ajustement
je dirais de certains crédits européens
la politique spatiale sur quels c'est
vrai que par rapport à la proposition
entre guillemets finlandaise elle a été
relevé mais ce n'est pas encore tout à
fait cela le programme iter parce que si
la france ne parle pas du nucléaire qui
le fera et puis l' agence frontex parce
que ça reste je dirais pour la
protection de nos frontières
quelque chose d'essentiel c'est bien
l'enjeu principal de cet effort
financier substantiel que l'union visage
donc dans quelle mesure confortera t-il
la puissance européenne
à cet égard nous relevons avec
satisfaction la création d'un programme
union européenne de la santé
nous félicitons ainsi que le mécanisme
que le mécanisme juridique de filtrage
des investissements directs étrangers
dont la france a récemment obtenu le
renforcement se voit dotée de moyens
financiers vous pouvez vous nous en dire
plus sur son montant et ses modalités de
mise en oeuvre
l'ambition que propose comme si on
reprenne a un prix elle passe par un
relèvement du plafond de ressources de
l'union
pouvez vous nous en nous éclairer à ce
sujet sur la justification du relèvement
permanente ce plafond que réclame la
commission et qui viendraient en plus du
relèvement temporaire nécessaire pour
financer le plan de relance pour notre
pays quel sera le prix de cette nouvelle
ambition européenne même si la nouvelle
facilité pour la reprise et la
résilience bénéficiera surtout aux états
les plus touchés dont le nôtre
le financement de ce plan de relance
implique assurément la création de
nouvelles ressources propres pour
l'union la commission étend le champ des
possibles en la matière c'est heureux
mais nous inquiétons de l'hypothèse
d'une nouvelle contribution qui elle
serait assise sur les grandes
entreprises
de quoi s'agit-il il ne faudrait pas que
ce plan reviennent en boomerang sur
l'économie européenne
il doit aussi s'accompagner d'une
révision de politique de concurrence ça
nous l'appelons de nos voeux je sais
qu'il ya une évolution de la réflexion
de madame vesta guerre que nous recevons
conjointement avec l'assemblée nationale
le 16 de ce mois le sénat depuis
pratiquement ses six ou sept ans avait
pointé du doigt la dérive en la matière
que ce soit sur le marché pertinent que
ce soit également sur le fait que nous
ne pouvions pas faire émerger des
champions européens
la réflexion s'est affinée il est grand
temps parce que je dirais je le dis
souvent le temps économique va beaucoup
plus vite que le temps politique et il
nous tarde je dirais de d'avoir
maintenant une feuille de route
exemplaire en la matière
donc sur ce point précis nous voudrions
également une optimisation de notre
politique commerciale au risque sinon de
bénéficier à nos concurrents quelle
assurance avant nous à cet égard jean
finira en vous interrogeant brillant
adam les ministres sur l'autre grand
sujet de ce conseil européen l'issue de
la négociation sur la relation future
avec le royaume uni nous sommes
interrogatif ladislas et moi même et
beaucoup d'autres cette négociations
patinent visiblement elle aurait même eu
je dirais raison du calme du flegme flag
non mais calme d'un autre négociateur
qui avoue sa lassitude je le dernier
avoue sa lassitude
cette négociation paix patine je le
répète chacun campant sur ses positions
notre partenaire britannique ne veut pas
jouer les prolongations entend restaurer
sa compétitivité en sa carte en
s'écartant des normes européennes
le parlement vient d'habilité le
gouvernement à prendre par ordonnance
les mesures qui seraient nécessaires
faute d'accord en fin d'année vous le
savez j'aimerais jouer malgré tout de la
conclusion en cmp d'une période
relativement convenable pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que le gouvernement ait
une certaine latitude en la matière il
était pourtant prévu d'ici la fin de ce
mois de conclure au moins sur le volet
pêche est ce que vous auriez des
informations que nous ne vous nous
n'avons pas encore la matière pour le
moment ce dossier est également parti
mans bloqué et donc ma question à quoi
doivent s'attendre je dirais nos
pêcheurs européens et français en
particulier
je laisse maintenant la parole au
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances puis ensuite au président de la
commission des affaires étrangères
voilà merci du président la ministre que
le plaisir à retrouver mais sur
collègues donc
nous avons ce matin le calendrier comme
ça à 10h30
bruno le maire olivier du soft pour la
présentation du plfr du troisième plfr
donc été présenté hier en conseil des
ministres est donc un syndrome de
questions sont entrés directement liés à
cette articulation entre la politique
française mesures de relance et la
politique européenne et donc l'ordre du
jour du conseil européen vous le savez
dédié évidemment à la réponse maintenant
économique à cette crise sanitaire
en se focalisant notamment sur les
orientations du prochain cadre financier
pluriannuel qui sur la mise en place de
ce fonds de relance donc la proposition
qui a été adopté mardi par la commission
des affaires européennes à l'initiative
de vous monsieur le président aidé de
simon sutour sera examinée mardi
prochain par sur le rapport de
jean-françois rapin en commission des
finances
et ne vous savez que le 27 mai dernier
la commission des affaires commission
européenne pardon a présenté ses
orientations sur le nouveau cadre
pluriannuel cadre financier pluriannuel
ainsi que sur le flanc drôle de plans de
relance
pièce maîtresse le centre l'élément
central de ce plan c'est la facilité
pour la reprise et la résilience avec
250 milliards d'euros de prêts et 310
milliards d'euros de subventions 305
je pense qu'il faut compléter ou
corriger si les chiffres sont bons donc
tous les cas une des subventions et des
prêts et s'accompagne évidemment les
premières mesures qu'on avait eue
pendant pendant la crise notamment le
mécanisme européen de stabilité
la mobilisation de l'abbaye notamment et
le mécanisme de refinancement de
l'assurance chômage alors ma première
question porte précisément sur la
réponse européenne en matière économique
et quel regard portez vous sur ces
chiffres ils sont à la fois élevé
des dizaines et dizaines de milliards
mais on a eu hier pierre moscovici qui
portait un regard à travers le haut
conseil
un peu mitigé qui disait sans doute il
ya des éléments ce qui peut vous montrer
que la reprise pourrait intervenir plus
tôt mais en même temps il ya des
facteurs de risque donc c'est un peu la
réponse où je citais paul claudel le
soulier de satin le pire n'est pas
toujours sûr c'est un petit peu ce qui
nous est dit d'ailleurs donc c'est les
chiffres sont à la fois important mais
avec relativiser par rapport aux besoins
considérables vous avez vu les
statistiques
hier de croissance qui sont annoncés
pour certaines sont bien au delà démence
% annoncés par le gouvernement - 14 %
par an pour le c d e
donc si les besoins notamment de leur
hobby sud était plus important est ce
que cette réponse est suffisante
est-ce que c'est nature a joué un rôle
macroéconomique significatif notamment
pour les secteurs qui sont quasi arrêt
je ne pense pas simplement aller rien je
ne pense pas simplement au tourisme il
ya beaucoup de secteurs qu'on n'envisage
pas hier on me parlait je crois que si
présent vous êtes sensible à amples des
transporteurs des amateurs de bateaux
entre la france et l'angleterre qui doit
aujourd'hui quasiment aucun parce qu'ils
n'ont quasiment pas de trafic donc ici
ne sont pas si par le dispositif de
chômage partiel ne perdure pas ces
entreprises ne pourront pas survivre
mais il ya des milliers et des milliers
de secteurs auxquels on ne pense pas les
sous traitants de par exemple du
tourisme et ses premières questions de
manière très concrète
est ce que cette réponse est suffisante
et nature a joué un rôle significatif
sur le plan macroéconomique
alors évidemment en permettant de lever
de l'argent sur les marchés financiers
ce plan de relance est présente à double
à terre ils présentent du bar l'intérêt
de réduire le coût durée du financement
pour les états notamment qui emprunte au
plus cher donc ça limite la
fragmentation au sein de la zone euro
est par ailleurs ça
n'accentue pas la pression sur les états
puisque les remboursements
n'interviendrait pas tout de suite
interviendrait qu'à côté de 2028
la france est dans une situation un peu
particulière parce que elle emprunte à
des conditions financières encore
intéressante avec un coût d'endettement
qui est faible donc l'intérêt plus
limité par an que pour un pays d'europe
du sud alors une question évidemment sur
le calendrier je disais remboursement à
partir de 2028
c'est un point qui reste à clarifier là
dessus on a un peu limité on n'a pas
encore beaucoup d'attenté de réponses
salle et c'est sans doute lié à la
réponse sur les ressources propres de
l'union européenne en tous les cas c'est
comment les états remboursera 11 sur
lequel modalités coques non ça on sait
que la contribution de la france obligée
de l'union européenne devrait augmenter
je parle sous le contrôle du président
la commission d'environ 6 milliards
d'euros alors là la question très simple
à la ministre avez-vous des précisions
sur les modalités de remboursement de
cet emprunt alors aujourd'hui c'est très
bien on dit on va vous donner de
l'argent mais on s'est un peu
particulier je pense que aucune banque
ne procéderait comme ça du mois les
clients auraient très peur on vous
donnera plus tard et des modalités
exactes de remboursement et pour la
france de manière très précise qu'elle
devrait être la part de remboursement
qui doit être assumée par la france à
partir de 2028 selon quel échéancier
qu'elle doit et le dernier point qui
intéresse la commission des finances
c'est un point important également c'est
la question de l'articulation de ce plan
européen avec le plan français qui
traduit en partie mais j'étais en de
manière très imparfaite
dans ce plfr 3 que nous allons examiner
prochainement il s'appelle fr3 comporte
un certain nombre de mesures de
résilience ou de relance mais pour
l'essentiel à part
quelques secteurs comme le tourisme
comme l'automobile l'aéronautique des
mesures de relance global je pense que
nous les attendons plutôt fait
grandement les prépare plutôt pour le
plf pour le plan à l'automne et ça nous
paraît pour notre part à un peu tard
dans tous les cas il ya beaucoup de
secteurs qui ministre est aujourd'hui
d'être encouragée soit pour
l'investissement soit pour la
consommation alors est-ce que donc nous
avons ce plan européen est la question
la troisième question de manière très
précise quelles sont pour vous madame la
ministre les secteurs qui devraient
bénéficier en priorité de ces crédits
européens et qu'ils méritent d'être
soutenus est ce que c'est de la
recherche les allemands vous avez les
annonces sur l'hydrogène ou sur d'autres
se la modernisation de l'industrie
voilà quels sont les secteurs qui
devraient en bénéficier en priorité et
comment assurer une synergie ou une
articulation avec le plan de relance
français le plan national voilà merci
beaucoup de votre attention sur ces
questions qui évidemment dont l'intérêt
dépasse celui des commissaires de la
commission des finances que nous sommes
tous conscients qu'on est très soucieux
de voir et de retrouver une croissance
qui sera le seul moyen de sauver merci
monsieur le rapporteur général
le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
moi aussi je peux être sortir des sujets
purement concernés par la commission de
la défense et des affaires étrangères
je voudrais madame ministre évoqué 3 3
points particuliers le premier comme
vous l'a bien dit le président bizet le
fonds européens de la défense
nous sommes très inquiets dans notre
commission
ça n'a aucun lien avec vous mais chaque
fois que vous ne venez nous voyons se
font diminuer vous est venue l'envié
vous dit rien et vous n'y êtes pour rien
rassurez vous laissez moi vous taquine
et j'adore ça vous êtes venu une fois on
était à 10 7 milliards
puis on était à 10 milliards et
aujourd'hui il ya plus que 8 milliards
le président biya parler de variable
d'ajustement et c'est vrai ce fonds
européens de la défense de cesse de
diminuer
on ne sait pas où il va terminer ça ne
devient plus du tout une priorité et je
pense que c'est une erreur
c'est une erreur pour pour les pays qui
ont des industries d'armement c'est vrai
tous les pays ne se sentent pas
concernés de la même manière mais la
france est un des pays qui est très
concerné compte tenu du nombre
d'entreprises qui sont dans ce secteur
du nombre de centaines de milliers de
salariés qui travaillent si on parle des
sous traitants maintenant et ce n'est
pas rassurant de voir que cette variable
d'ajustement varie ne cesse de varier en
baissant est bon la question madame la
ministre je vous demande pas si vous
avez des informations là dessus vous ne
savez pas ce qui va sortir du prochain
conseil mais est ce que la france va
pouvoir exprimer d'une mort forte le
fait que ça suffit nous ne voulons pas
que ça continue de baisser
le second point madame la ministre cours
également sur lequel la commission a les
inquiétudes c'est le problème de la
rupture et la réouverture des frontières
ça devait être au niveau européen
coordonné et ça ne l'est pas si vous
regardez tous les soirs le journal
télévisé vous voyez que les pays qui
sont beaucoup plus concerné comme tulle
évoqué l'enchère albéric par le tourisme
et et l'importance du tourisme dans leur
activité économique
on voit que des pays comme la grèce
l'italie le portugal sont déjà en train
de préparer leur place ouvrent leurs
frontières alors que d'autres pays
continuent à avoir des frontières
fermées
de toutes les façons ce problème
d'ouverture fermeture est lié à un autre
problème le problème des transports
aériens et la lots
ollier temps qu'on débloque pas l'un on
peut pas débloquer l'autre mais pas
question madame la ministre est simple
est-ce que vous pensez que la conseil
européen il pourrait y avoir enfin une
chouette une politique je dirais de
coopération pour que tout le monde fasse
la même chose au même moment nous sommes
moins actif que les trois pays que
j'aime vos cités mais le tourisme est
très important pour nous tous savons
très bien que nous n'aurons pas les
touristes des continents américains ou
asiatiques
nous avons absolument besoin que
l'activité touristique européenne
redémarre et là aussi un ministre
quelle va être la position que la france
va défendre je veux pas qu est-ce qui va
se décider
on ne sait pas ce qui va se décider
troisième et dernier point et là vous me
permettrez de dire rester un tout petit
peu plus longtemps je sors peut-être un
petit peu en dehors de la commission le
plan le plan de relance j'avoue que le
dalo que les inquiétudes
la réunion des ministres des finances a
montré quoi à tous les désaccords qui
sortait qui surgissait de des 27 pays
cette réunion des ministres des finances
étaient faites pour préparer la réunion
de la semaine la semaine prochaine des
chefs d'état des chefs de gouvernement
et on a vu les positions des uns et des
autres est sûr qu'à point bien précis on
voit on voit se dessiner ses désaccords
et ses divisions
le premier que notre rapporteur a évoqué
sur le calendrier
l'objectif a pris hier le départ annoncé
c'est d'aller vite mais quand on voit la
vitesse à laquelle avance le cadre
financier pluriannuel que tu a
longuement évoqué et toi aussi
ça fait des mois qu'on discute il sort
pas moi je ne suis pas rassuré sur ce
plan de relance de 750 milliards
je ne suis pas sûr que l'objectif qui
était de le sortir avant fin août de
manière à ce que les différents
programmes de relance de chacun des pays
puisse être engagée les actions puissent
être engagées en début d'année 2021
je vois pas du tout comment ce
calendrier
peut être tenu sept de mon point de vue
une mission impossible
deuxième inquiétude les réticences des
pays dits frugaux ils sont nombreux les
pays frigo comme vous le savez tous ce
sont l'autriche les pays bas danemark la
suède la finlande le réticences porte
surtout portent d'abord sur le montant
pourtant suite sur la répartition des
750 milliards je pense que le plan qui
est proposé en prairies n'est pas
mauvais puisque ce serait 500 milliards
sous forme de subventions et 250
milliards sous forme de prêts les pays
frigoul sont absolument pas d'accord il
ne sanctionne pas d'accord ils trouvent
que la part en suivant sur les trouve
importantes
il était au départ pour une aide oui
mais sous forme de prêt beaucoup plus
importante que ce qui est prévu
et là aussi je ne voudront pas ce qui va
sortir de ce conseil européen mais je
vous demande quelle va être la position
que la france va défendre vis-à-vis de
ses réticences la troisième inquiétudes
troisième inquiétude ce sont les
critères de répartition
là aussi on voit nouvelle vision les
critères de répartition de ses 750
milliards quelle que soit la forme
suivant sur ou près tiennent compte tels
que cette annonce est de 3 critères
importants
la taille des états le pib par habitant
et le chômage
oui mais mais ce sont des critères qui
seraient des critères retenus en
fonction de chief d'avant la crise ce
qui est très surprenant
autrement dit les enveloppes qui vont
être attribués à chacun des pays
votre fonction de la situation de la
taille du p du pib et du chômage d'avant
la crise alors que c'est un plan de
relance pour redresser après la crise du
coup on a des résultats stupéfiants dans
ce qui serait proposé un pays comme la
grèce qui a été très peu frappés par la
crise va être très bien servi un pays
comme la être la série
proportionnellement à ce qu'il
représente un pays comme la pologne qui
a une crise sanitaire et une crise
économique plutôt limité
va être parmi les plus gros
bénéficiaires
la belgique vous le savez puisque les
chiffres en termes de morts et de
personnes frappées par la crise
sanitaire belgique va être très peu
aidés et voyez c'est là où les frigos
dral et même d'autres pays de l'est de
l'europe de l'union européenne sur
n'additionne l'italie l'espagne et la
france
ils vont recevoir la moitié de l'aide de
l'union européenne
c'est de la provoc et on comprend qu'il
y ait des désaccords un petit peu
partout et donc sur ces critères madame
la ministre
j'aimerais connaître votre position je
veux dire est ce qu'ils vont bouger et
notamment sur la base des critères et
des chiffres et des données reçues
d'avant et ont décrit ces derniers
dernier dernière inquiétude
bruce a dansé l'avant dernière passe
qu'un facilier l'un et l'autre sont liés
bruxelles va porter un jugement sur les
plans de relance de chacun des pays ça a
été un non la commission a annoncé
notamment de critères qui sont peut-être
objectifs certains happé par toi
président sur la troisième la part
importante de transition verte
d'objectifs numérique
mais comme le critère le plus important
ça va être de porter un jugement sur le
détail des réformes qui vont permettre
d'accélérer la reprise
ça n'est pas un critère objectif ce sera
un critère très subjectif qui peut être
dangereux et qui va accélérer et le
dernier inquiétudes toujours sur ce plan
et là je n'ai pas mes temps parce que
albéric s'était enduit ce sont les
désaccords sur les remboursements
les désaccords continue sur les
remboursements il continue non pas sur
le fait que c'est un emprunt qu'on va
commencer à rembourser en 2028 et qui
pour financer on va faire un emprunt sur
trente ans
là dessus il semblerait que tout le
monde soit mais c'est que pour financer
cet emprunt
là il ya des désaccords entre tous les
pays puisque on va le financer grâce à
des taxes c'est ce que propose la
commission un des tags sur le numérique
les taxes sur les émissions de co2 des
taxes sur les multinationales et des
taxes sur les produits peuvent faire
l'est des actions polluantes mais tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord et 27 sont
tout à fait divisés sur la part de
chacune de ces taxes qui sera prélevée
pour payer cet emprunt donc encore des
divisions là aussi à la ministre
quelle va être la position de force
c'est ce que nous allons nous mouiller
sur la manière de rembourser cet emprunt
géant qui va être fait je conclurai
blâmait ministre en disant je permettant
non plus puisqu'on en a beaucoup débattu
dans l'hémicycle
il n'y a pas très longtemps sur le break
site je ne suis pas rassurée par nous ne
sommes pas rassurés la commission des
affaires étrangères par la conférence de
presse qu'a tenus michel barnier suite
dû dire la dernière rencontre
non seulement ils y voient un blocage
sur tous les sujets qui restent à
discuter mais il nous a annoncé dans sa
conférence de presse que sur certains
sujets sur lesquels il y avait eu un
accord
les anglais sont en train de revenir et
de remettre sur le tapis
et sur ces deux points là que je connais
sur lesquels vous travaillez énormément
madame la ministre
j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue bon
je pense que c'est très mal parti
de même que je pense qu'il ne va pas
sortir grand chose du prochain conseil
européen je suis peu optimiste vous avez
vu merci madame la ministre
réponse que vous apporterez à ces
inquiétudes
merci on ladislas dames la ministre
beaucoup de questions
autant de réponses auxquelles vous ne le
dirais n'échapperez pas je le sais merci
monsieur le président est monsieur le
rapporteur général shair mesdames les
sénatrices et messieurs les sénateurs
g13 heureuse de vous retrouver pour déjà
un grand nombre d'entre vous comme on
dit en chaire et en os même si c'est
encore dans un format restreint ici
palais du luxembourg
l'épidémie on le voit est toujours parmi
nous mais que nous avons gagné contre
elle une première manche
les signaux sont encourageants donc tout
en restant prudent je crois que nous
allons pouvoir progressivement retrouver
une vie normale qu'il sent qu'il s'agit
tout à fait on voit aujourd'hui de la
vie d'avant mais la prochaine réunion
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement se
tiendra effectivement vendredi prochain
toujours par visioconférence qui est
bien un signe des temps exceptionnels
que nous vivons c'est bien la cinquième
fois depuis le début de la crise que ses
membres du conseil européen se réunisse
dans ce format rappelons que cet inédit
et que la première de ces
visioconférence s'était tenue le 10 mars
à la demande d'ailleurs du président la
république auprès de charles michel pour
qu'il y ait au plus haut niveau européen
une instance à la fois de décision de
coordination d'impulsion et je crois
qu'il faut s'en rappeler même si c'était
finalement il n'y a pas si longtemps
mais ça nous semble déjà un temps nous
avons vécu beaucoup de choses entre
temps je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
pour présenter les enjeux cette
discussion elle sera effectivement
centrée sur les enjeux de la relance
économique de l'union sur le cadre
financier pluriannuel le 2021 et 2027
et puis il y aura aussi un point sur
l'état des lieux des négociations sur la
relation future et au royaume uni et je
vais revenir vendredi prochain il faut
qu'on est bien en tête effectivement que
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement vont
discuter d'un pack est constitué de deux
jambes une jambe qui est celui du fonds
de relance plan de relance présenté le
27 mai dernier
mais une autre jambe qui est celui du
budget européen 2021 et 2027 un peu
éclipsé devant la nouveauté du plan de
relance mais je pense qu'il faut
toujours voir la dynamique du paquet
vous le savez cette proposition repose
vous l'avez tous souligné sur le
principe d'un emprunt européen pour la
partie de la relance il
c'est un vrai changement de paradigme
et il ya trois mois je crois qu'il était
venu ici vous dire que dans trois mois
nous serions en train de discuter d'un
tel emprunt vous m'auriez dit que
j'étais quand même très irréaliste que
c'était quand même encore un tabou que
c'était pour certains contraire aux
traités que c'était remettre en cause la
bonne gestion financière bref vous avez
irresponsable nous voyons la crise a
changé la donne et je crois que nous
avons tous compris que nous avions
besoin d'une europe et d'une réponse
européenne massive que les outils
budgétaires nous disposions à l'échelle
européenne étaient insuffisants face aux
besoins et que les taux d'intérêt
étaient suffisamment faible pour que
nous puissions recouvrir alors recourir
à l'emprunt dans de bonnes conditions
c'est pourquoi le président république
avait pris l'initiative avec huit autres
de ses homologues européens je vous
rappelle lesquels la belgique l'espagne
la grèce l'irlande l'italie le
luxembourg le portugal la slovénie deux
plaidé dès le 26 mars dernier auprès du
président du conseil européen pour un
mécanisme d'endettement commun et à
l'époque il faut le dire l'accueil avait
été assez réservés
le président a néanmoins je crois avec
beaucoup de persévérance comme il le
fait depuis trois ans chercher à avancer
donc c'est pour cela que les contacts
très réguliers ont été lancées que la
chancelière notamment pour que nous
puissions partager notre conviction face
à l'interdépendance économique
fondamentale créé par ce marché européen
qui a fait notre prospérité
nous avons l'obligation d'avoir aussi
une réponse européenne à la hauteur des
enjeux de ses conséquences et que donc
nous avons l'exigence d'une réponse
forte rapide sans état d'âme et donc
lors de leur dernière réunion du 23
avril sur la base des travaux des
ministres des finances les chefs d'état
de gouvernement ont d'ailleurs reconnu
et c'était là aussi une étape importance
la nécessité et l'urgence de la création
d'un fonds de relance et ont mandaté la
commission pour qu'elle précise les
besoins que c'est que ces montants dont
on parle s'appuie sur une une revue
économique des besoins et présente une
proposition à la hauteur des enjeux
c'était donc une première étape une
seconde étape a été franchie
vous l'avez tous je crois bien noté le
18 mai dernier lors d'une initiative
franco-allemande qui est historique
je crois que beaucoup n'ont pas
forcément souligné
non seulement le volet budgétaire
financier 500 milliards d'euros que nous
proposions cet endettement commun du
financement subventions en direct à des
secteurs les régions touchées
on voit bien là qu'on ne finance pas le
déficit courant de tel ou tel état
il y avait aussi dans cette proposition
la vraie volonté de créer une nouvelle
aux feuilles de route pour l'europe une
feuille de route de souveraineté à la
fois dans la santé dans l'industrie
transition écologique et je crois qu'on
a parfois éclipsé le côté fondateur non
seulement sur le plan financier mais
j'étais à moitié sur le plan politique
on verra si c'était un moment
hamiltonien mais ce qui est certain
c'est que cette initiative franco
allemande a déjà contribué à nous faire
passer une tape majeurs c'est à dire que
nous avons fondamentalement modifier les
équilibres entre les états membres nous
avons déplacé centre de gravité au
conseil je crois que c'est le succès
d'une méthode c'est le succès de cette
idée que la france et l'allemagne
peuvent faire des propositions
constructives qu'elles peuvent expliquer
qu'elles peuvent rassembler et je crois
que d'ailleurs vous l'avez tous vu ces
propositions ont été bien accueillie par
la plupart des partenaires ont
effectivement isolé d'une certaine
manière les états membres les plus durs
vous mais qualifié de frugaux l'autriche
les pays-bas nationale mais je remarque
néanmoins que c'est pas un bloc uni je
me rends ce soir en autriche je serai
lundi aux pays bas je peux vous dire que
les entreprises néerlandaises les
entreprises autrichiennes les syndicats
néerlandais les syndicats autrichiens
sont d'accord avec ce plan et que les
demandes de la suède du danemark de
l'autriche les pays-bas ne sont pas les
mêmes
donc nous n'avons pas devant nous un
bloc et je crois d'ailleurs nous
récusons cette logique de bloc nous
avons devant nous des pays qui ont des
demandes des réponses à tapas se voir
apporter qu'il faut que nous comprenions
bien ce dont ils ont besoin pour pouvoir
bien travailler avec nous il ya des
nuances y en a aussi au sein du groupe
de visegrad vous faudra reparler
et comme l'a dit jean yves le drian avec
une pointe d'humour les frigos doivent
manger un peu et nous savons très bien
les interdépendances commerciales
économiques que nous avons tous les uns
avec les autres
c'est donc dans ce contexte de dynamique
favorable que la commission européenne a
présenté le 27 mai cette proposition de
relance en lien avec donc une révision
du cadre financier pluriannuel
1021 2027 effectivement on voulait tous
souligné la nouveauté c'est ce plan de
relance de 750 milliards d'euros
financés par l'emprunt
je suis important général en a précisé
les différents instruments
l'objectif de ce fonds de relance et de
renforcer notre budget de l'union
jusqu'en 2024
quasiment le double et pendant ces
années si vous regardez les différentes
enveloppes via donc un instrument
financier permettant de lever des fonds
sur les marchés financiers
les trois quarts des financements levés
560 milliards viendront donc financer un
nouvel instrument la facile et de
relance et de résilience 310 milliards
de subventions 250 milliards de prêts
avec une clé de répartition vous l'avez
souligné spécifiques
tout cela peut bien sûr discuté avec la
navigation gervais de rares détails et
elle permettrait de financer des plans
de relance nationaux que chaque pays
présenterait à la commission pour
intégrer les priorités de l'union
notamment en matière climatique et
numérique donc monsieur rapporteur
général quand vous interrogez on demande
pas la commission valide nos plans mais
si nous voulons avoir de relance
européen qui crée de la prospérité par
la compétition mais il faut s'assurer
que nous marchons dans une dit dans une
direction complémentaires et donc chaque
pays voit bien ses besoins voit les
secteurs qui sont les plus les affecter
voit ses priorités comment notamment
cette transition écologique transition
numérique doit être axé dans son pays et
présente à la commission et qui a le
rôle non pas de sanctionner mais de
s'assurer que en fait ce qu'on propose
des années on va fonctionner et dont on
va pouvoir marcher et qu'on va pas se
rentrer dans une dynamique qui serait
une dynamique négative alors même que
nous voulons créer des emplois et créer
la paix de la croissance deuxième outil
de ce fonds de relance c'est 7 % de
cette enveloppe soit 50 5 milliards qui
viennent abonder un nouvel instrument de
cohésion à plairait axe you dont les
financements sont alloués en fonction de
l'impact de la crise très précisément
dans ce cas là avec donc une politique
cohésion qui re qui constitue un levier
de relance fondamental dans les
territoires les plus touchés
ça veut dire pour nous très concrètement
que ça passe par le canal des régions et
là nous aurons comme vous savez c'est
une petite marotte de mon côté mais je
crois qu'elle est nécessaire
nous avons besoin
que les régions puissent se mobiliser
pleinement qu'elle puisse simplifiée
aussi la capacité d'accéder à ces fonds
européens
dès les premières années du cadre
financier pluriannuel nous avons souvent
encore france nous avons toujours un
petit retard à l'allumage
nous ne pouvons pas alors que ce cas
financiers pour elle va commencer en une
21 qui valait donc en plus renforcée et
bien avoir les deux ou trois ans
habituel où nous mettons un peu de temps
à comprendre comment les choses
fonctionnent
cette fois ci ce ne sera pas ce sera pas
acceptable
vu le calendrier macroéconomique qui
nous entoure et puis enfin troisième
plan et le troisième point ce plan vient
abonder d'autres programmes déjà
existants nouvellement créé je pense à
invest i ue qui va être notamment
doubler pour atteindre 30 milliards
d'euros avec un volet sur les
investissements stratégiques j'y
reviendrai à monsieur le président qui
fait écho à votre question
le deuxième pilier de la pac également
réhaussé de 15 milliards d'euros le
fonds transition juste également en
augmentation de 30 milliards d'euros
horizon europe pour soutien et wanda
recherche ou encore là souvent de
voisinage et de coopération avec
notamment un soutien de l'aide
humanitaire pour renforcer notre action
extérieure
et puis vous l'avez dit un nouveau
programme consacré à la santé de 10
milliards d'euros là aussi très
important la commission a par ailleurs
au delà de tout ça proposer des
ajustements sur certains programmes du
budget européen du cfp notamment au vu
des discussions que nous avons eues en
février la pac viendrai voir son budget
augmenter y compris là avec des
augmentations qui concernerait comme
vous savez là deux points attention nous
avons sur le premier pilier
ce qui pour nous est une avancée que
nous saluions et je sais à quel point le
sénat sur ces sujets et vigilants cela
valide profond ce que nous disons depuis
trois ans que je vous ai souvent ici la
politique agricole commune est une vraie
poésie de souveraineté et je vois que
700 cette crise sanitaire est venu le
démontrer s'il fallait encore en
convaincre certains pouvoir s'alimenter
avec des produits qui viennent de pas
trop loin de chez soi c'est évidemment
extrêmement précieux en temps de crise
nous serons extrêmement vigilants sur le
fait que ce niveau d'ambition proposé
par la commission ne soit pas revue à la
baisse et vous pouvez compter avec
guillaume mobilisation vous pouvez aussi
compter sur la coalition en fonte
d'allier que nous avons sur ce sujet
solide et vous pouvez compter sur fait
que le président république sur ce sujet
là comme beaucoup d'autres veillera en
pleine cohérence avec ce que nous vous
disons depuis quelques temps déjà
si on regarde maintenant le terrain de
jeu en amont de cette réunion de
vendredi
il ya eu un accueil très positif de la
plupart voire des très nombreuses et à
vendre mais il faut qu'on se dise la
vérité ça va être des négociations
difficiles parce qu'il ya de multiples
paramètres qu'ils vont être intégrés
vous n'avez citer les uns et les autres
un certain nombre nous préparons le 16
juin prochain mardi prochain une réunion
des ministres affaires européennes qui
nous permettront de partager les
premières orientations et puis de
montrer comment nous français nous avons
des lignes rouges au fond des points de
vigilance particulier ce que je pense
qu'il va ressortir de ces discussions où
chacun va pouvoir aussi réagir un peu
formellement cette proposition on prend
le calendrier
les chefs d'état de gouvernement
missionne la commission pour réfléchir
pendant lance les initiatives franco
allemandes explique ce que nous pensons
être à la hauteur de la crise la propre
la commission fait une proposition
c'est normal qu'on ait un moment où
chacun peut donc maintenant réagir
formellement dans les points discutés à
l' architecture et le montant du fonds
du plan de relance
il ya effectivement des fortes pressions
pour que certains en rient en baisser le
niveau réhausser la part des prêts
instaurer des conditionnalités très
forte si et des éventuels transferts
budgétaires donc ça c'est un point
discussion je pense que on voit bien que
c'est un sur une diction on voit bien
aussi qu'il faut qu'on reste cohérent et
ambitieux avec les besoins qui ont pu
être exprimés deuxième enjeu c'est
effectivement la répartition des moyens
dans les programmes du budget parce que
les modalités de la nouvelle facilité de
relance et de résilience ses objectifs
la clé de répartition entre états
membres sa gouvernance là aussi le rôle
du parlement européen sont des enjeux
qui vont être discutés et puis un
troisième point est très important et
vous en vous connaissez pour nous
l'important c'est le débat sur les
ressources propres et les rabais sur ces
deux points
la commission laisse à ce stade un
changer ces propositions initiales
elle rappelle néanmoins et c'est très
important pour nous
la pertinence des ressources propres
pour aider à financer le remboursement
du plan de relance et elle propose et
elle maintient sa profession d'une
sortie progressive du système des rabais
tout en invoquant la possibilité horizon
plus lointain pour qu'il disparaisse et
nous savons tous ici que c'est un
élément important du compromis que nous
aurons à trouver côté français je vais
être rapide mais je pense qu'il faut que
vous soyez clairs sur ce que nous
portons avec le président la république
1 le paquet de 500 milliards de
subventions budgétaires c'est un point
dur c'est un minimum
nous avons besoin pour relancer notre
économie et pour répondre à porte en
général il ya trois ans en fondant notre
plan d'action national et européen est
d'abord protéger les emplois répondre à
l'urgence c'est ce que nous avons fait
jusqu'à maintenant
c'est ce que tous les plfr ont mis en
route c'est ce que dans l'urgence la
commission européenne avait débloqué il
ya un deuxième temps qui est celui du
renforcement l'économie de la relance et
c'est là où ce plan de relance européen
a un rôle majeur à jouer pour que ce
soit cohérent parce que notre secteur
automobile il est européen
parce que les pièces détachées les
clients sont largement diffusés sur le
continent européen
et puis un troisième temps qu' investir
pour l'avenir que les emplois concret
sur les emplois du ray durable pérenne
qui sodas les emplois qu'ils soient ce
que la transition écologique nous impose
de créer que soit ce que la transition
numérique nous impose de créer et donc
là on a besoin du budget européen budget
jusqu'en 2027 pour qu'on ait un horizon
de temps devant nous deuxième point
c'est le financement par la dette qui
doit être maintenue à nos yeux les
modalités de remboursement doivent pour
nous intégrer des ressources propres
pour qu'on puisse aller j'ai là la
partie reviendra à la hausse de la
contribution nationale
c'est très important vous savez parce
que dans la construction technique
aujourd'hui ce que propose la commission
c'est qu'on paye tous les intérêts de
cet emprunt d'ici 2027 donc avec une
forme de prévisibilité et que nous
commencions à rembourser le principal à
partir de 2000 28 sont très longues
tous quand on s'aime en 2058 et que ce
remboursement du principal nous
cherchons à ce qu'ils soient le plus
possible financée par des ressources
propres pour limiter la hausse des
contributions nationales ça veut dire
évidemment vous savez la contribution
plastique
la contribution de ts mais nous
cherchons et nous avons objectivement
fait énormément de progrès sur ce
mécanisme d'inclusion carbone aux
frontières
je me souviens avoir été dans votre
hémicycle
pour et bien en discuter projet ô
combien vous avez compris en france
comme étant nécessaire cette
mondialisation ou cherchant à réguler
aujourd'hui qui progresse pour que notre
effort climatique soit cohérent avec le
commerce que nous avons autour de nous
la taxe numérique sur les gaffes à
justice puisqu'elle est évidemment
puisque ces entreprises vont bénéficier
la relance européenne
je serais quand même bien qu'elle
contribue aussi à notre prospérité mais
en tout cas au remboursement de cet
effort de relance
et puis la taxe les transactions
financières qui restent à nos plus
importants dernier point sur le cfp
apprend à proprement parler la pac
je vous en ai parlé notamment premier
pied sur le fond défense
le chiffre joue là je m'informe ses 9
milliards ont été redescendus à 7
on est aujourd'hui à 9 milliards on
était mort est décédée à 5 un moment
donné la provision finlandaise en
février charles michel en vert montait à
aujourd'hui on est à 9 vous voyez quand
julien il ya parfois au ciné chiffres à
la hausse comme ça on les quitte le
président le dira lors de la
visioconférence
je crois que le sens d'ailleurs la
tribune hier de josette borel et tirez
vos routes on va dans ce sens nous
devons affirmer la souveraineté ça se
passe dans beaucoup de domaines ça se
passe évidemment dans le plan de la
défense est aussi un élément crédibilité
de puissance face à la chine face aux
états unis on a pour objectif de
dépasser
on dit à un montant à deux chiffres
c'est notre combat et vous pouvez
compter sur moi je le dirai à nouveau
mardi bien sûr omise affaires
européennes sur l'espace on a aussi un
peu plus à faire si on veut être
notamment cohérent avec ce qui s'était
passé à la ministérielle de l'agencé
spatiale européenne au sur iter
évidemment aujourd'hui il nous manque
400 millions je vous rappelle les
montants on a quand même déjà augmenté
le financement entre 2014 et 2020
c'était 3 milliards pour 2021 et 2027
la commission avait proposé initialement
5,4 milliards on est aujourd'hui à 5
milliards
on va essayer de remonter c'est
évidemment une priorité notamment dans
le cadre de l'investissement climatique
et puis enfin il nous semble
indispensable et je tiens vraiment ici à
le dire avec beaucoup de solennité
s'il faut une relance n'est pas
disponible pour la relance taxi nous
n'arrivons pas à nous mettre d'accord en
juillet là on a un problème et donc il
ya une obligation de résultats très
forts ce calendrier et madame merkel
notamment est très consciente sa
présidence allemande
conseils de présence allemande de
l'union européenne doit commencer par un
accord du mois de juillet sinon on va
être totalement décalé et effectivement
dans ce cas là on pourrait se poser des
questions à la fois de cohérence et il
faut qu'on puisse synchronisée notre
plan européen avec ensuite ce que seront
les plans de relance nationaux dont
qu'on ait de la visibilité et c'est pour
ça que l'on m'ait est présent dans le
public ils passent énormément de temps
pour créer les conditions d'un accord en
juillet cette négociation est d'autant
plus complexe et effectivement on voit
que le calendrier serré nous allons
intensifier nos efforts
il ya beaucoup d'échangés la fois
bilatéraux sur un groupe à tous les
niveaux et nous espérons que après le
tour de table
la discussion du 19 juin au puissions
avoir probablement fin juin une version
révisée de la boyne de négociation qui
sera un support à l'accord politique
c'est une robe elle avance par étapes
je pense qu'il faut qu'avec méthode on
puisse se donner des rendez vous je
voulais 10 juin en autriche un aux pays
bas on échange avec tout le monde et on
cherche est dans une logique de goût
voilà 2 qu'est-ce qu'on rajoute au
paquet au fond pour que chacun puisse
s'y retrouver et puisque défend projet
déjà été un peu longue
très rapidement sur le brésil parce que
je pense que et les négociations sur les
relations futures
je sais que j'imagine qu'ils auraient
des questions et je pense c'est
important elles ont été ralenties ces
négociations par la situation sanitaire
parce qu'être des suspendus purent se
repréparer visioconférence on voit bien
que les divergences sont profondes
qu'elles demeurent il ya déjà eu ni vers
man sur la méthode de négociation les
britanniques souhait d'avancer sur les
sujets qui les intéressent en priorité
l'union défend une approche et je pense
que on le comprendra global parce qu'on
veut un parallélisme des progrès je les
différentes dimensions la négociation
notamment sur la base des termes de
négociation discuter avec les
britanniques il faut que ce mandat ne
puisse avancer de manière parallèle il
ya un comité conjoint qui se réunira le
12 juin entre les équipes de négociation
rencontre de haut niveau qui est prévue
entre les représentants des institutions
qu'on se la font d'ailleurs bien sûr
cher michel en face boris johnson et des
roses équipes de négociation
celui ci si nous comprenons bien les
signaux envoyés devrait annoncer qu'il
ne souhaite pas étendre la période de
transition et que donc ses pairs de
transition toucherait à sa fin fin
décembre 2020 mais compte tenu des
d'approbation ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on boucle la négociation en quatre
mois ce qui sont objectivement
difficilement atteignable et donc nous
devons sans tarder nous préparer à tous
les scénarios et en particulier à celui
d'une absence d'accord commercial
on n'est plus dans la même situation que
celle qui prévalait avant nous ayons cet
accord politique en février dernier mais
on voit bien ce mois de juin va être un
mois crucial une échéance majeure
voilà peut-être sur différents points
techniques avant qu'on passe aux
questions si vous le souhaitez je le
président puisque vous avez eu des
points que je n'ai pas pu aborder aussi
détaillé que ce que j'aurais pu dans mon
propos liminaires sur la politique
concurrence vous savez c'est une
priorité française
vous vous souvenez la lettre qu'on avait
envoyé pologne france allemagne
notamment à la commission
vous avez vu que c'est aussi inscrit
dans l'initiative franco allemande
c'est pas du tout quelque chose qu'on a
mises sous le boisseau on voit bien que
dans cette crise une forte adaptation
ailleurs des mécanismes en jeu quand
vous êtes d'état et faute réactivité
c'est pour nous de perdre effort de
cohérence
on mène une bataille pour l'emploi en
mai une bataille pour la souveraineté
effectivement on voit qu'il faut qu'on
soit pleinement cohérent avec cette
politique industrielle qu'on veut mener
et vous pouvez compter sur la aussi
notre vigilance contre engagement mais
des choses intéressantes sont aussi en
train d'être réfléchi au niveau de la
commission sur la défense je crois que
vous ai apporté les éléments utiles sur
le remboursement également le fait que
je crois bien sûr important général
qu'on puisse payer tous les intérêts
entre 2021 et 2027 et rembourser le
principal en ayant le plus possible de
ressources propres européennes sur des
critères qui sont cohérents avec nos
ambitions notamment numériques et
climatique je pense que c'est un combat
important il ya une forme de solidarité
intertemporelle dans cette dynamique et
donc c'est des choses qui vont être
négociés précisé sur les investissements
stratégiques du président
ça fait partie de ce plan de relance 16
milliards de ll investi ue qui sont
dédiés
au fond à la protection des prédateurs
étrangers de nos secteurs stratégiques
pas que la santé on sait que ça concerne
d'autres secteurs on avait déjà renforcé
vous savez d'un dispositif national
il y avait donc déjà bien avant la crise
un dispositif européen
cette cet instrument de investi ou sur
la solvabilité inclut notamment un
soutien aux entreprises en difficulté
mais aussi donc vraiment une protection
des entreprises stratégiques avec
l'abbaye avec des garanties du budget
européen
les secteurs c'est la santé des
infrastructures critiques
le secteur vert et numérique où il ya
une forte innovation des stocks
stratégiques comment intègre j mais si
on réfléchit un peu plus largement
politiquement on a connu l'europe du
plan marshall c'était de l'argent
américain donner aux européens pour
qu'ils achètent des biens américains
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on vive aussi
un plan schuman cette manière c'est de
l'argent européen pour les européens
pour acheter des biens européens et ça
peut pas dire qu'on se ferme ça pas des
ronces quatre murs et pas devant les
protectionnistes mais on a besoin
d'avoir là aussi une cohérence sont des
efforts que nous demandons à nos
citoyens mais c'est normal que ça puisse
appuyer aussi une réindustrialisation
européenne sur les critères d'allocation
je pense qu'il faut vraiment penser les
choses aussi en termes d'indépendance
économique
moi je suis extrêmement attachée que on
revienne pas dans une logique de juste
retour que chacun discute alors presse
qui vous c'est ça fonctionne pour que ça
fonctionne il faut que nos entreprises
et des clients et des fournisseurs
et s'il ya des endroits des régions qui
ont été plus touchés par la crise ou qui
ont moins les moyens de rebondir qui ont
moins les moyens d'investir parce que
leur point de départ les méditations
plus difficile moi je suis pour qu'on
mette les moyens là où c'est nécessaire
parce qu'on voit bien je pense notamment
à l'automobile
le jour où le nord de l'italie ralentis
c'est tout le secteur automobile
européen qui ralentit et donc si c'est
là qu'il faut qu'on applique plus et on
est plus de moyens c'est pas à notre
détriment c'est un laveur c'est pour
qu'on puisse nous même repartir donc
effectivement c'est une négociation
difficile
il ya aussi on l'a vu des critères à
regarder sur le fond transition juste et
30 milliards de plus aujourd'hui si on
avait gardé les critères initiaux il y
avait deux départements français de
gibles dont vous dire que la capacité
d'absorption de ces deux départements
par rapport aux montants totalement
déraisonnable
donc là aussi on va chercher parce qu'on
a une bonne utilisation des fonds que
des conditionnalités sur l'étape droit
que cette répartition parts avant tout
des besoins économiques et consorts ans
qu'on arrête les logiques de boutiquiers
parce que c'est pas cohérent avec le
besoin économique d'aujourd'hui et puis
enfin je terminerais là sur les
frontières les transports et tourisme
bon les frontières intérieures c'est
très clair c'est la décision était prise
par les ministres de l'intérieur
la semaine dernière la plus grande
partie des frontières intérieures à
l'union européenne ne verront plus de
contrôle dès le 15 juin prochain a
annoncé lundi prochain nous avons
également noté que six dans certains
endroits pour des critères sanitaires il
ya une difficulté le 15 juin
on se donnait au maximum le 1er juillet
pour ces contrôles intérieurs soit levée
c'est pour les frontières intérieures sa
circulation des européens dans l'espace
européen
donc c'est schengen élargi ça comprend
le royaume uni ça comprend ces salles
l'espace c'est ça laisse pas ce qu'on
veut créer de circulation ensuite les
frontières extérieures et là on a posé
un principe clair c'est que jusqu'au 1er
juillet gardiens de régime que nous
connaissons depuis quelques mois
maintenant et qu'à partir du 1er juillet
nous cherchons à définir ensemble une
liste de pays pour que vous si vous
atterrissez à paris amsterdam quoi
francfort vouziers le même régime
parce que si on recrée un espace de
circulation intérieure si vous n'êtes
pas les mêmes règles sur le pays où vous
posez on voit bien ça n'a pas marché
donc on est en train de construire cette
liste sur des critères sanitaires
effectivement ce transport aérien on a
pris des mesures d'urgence sur les
créneaux aéroportuaires sur notamment
les redevances sur la prolongation un
certain nombre d' aide le report de
certaines règles
on a aussi ses chercher à coordonner nos
mesures sanitaires pour que selon
l'endroit vous décollez a priori il se
passe la même chose quand vous êtes dans
le ciel européen
on a une voix lance économique très
forte vous avez vu avec un paquet
national de 16 milliards et donc on voit
bien que on va aussi avoir des avances
des remboursements on est en train de
créer tout un plan pour que ce secteur
qui ont ces coeurs aussi de la
construction européenne elle-même puisse
tenir et avec une ambition très fortes
notamment son plan de la transition
écologique c'est avions ouvert en 2035
on voit bien que ça peut bénéficier du
financement européen sur le tourisme je
tiens à le dire je me sers de ce micro
pour le dire nous appelons les européens
vient passer leurs vacances en france à
partir du 15 juin ils seront remis pour
venir chez nous pourquoi je crois que
tout je crois que tous dans toutes les
zones vertes monsieur monsieur
montgolfier il ya des restaurants il ya
des terrasses donc nous cherchons à
regagner des choses pour qui la
confiance annie terme et jean-baptiste
lemoyne se mobilise énormément
d'ailleurs dans toute la presse
européenne pour rappeler que les
européens sont bienvenus en france à
partir du 15 juin et donc d'europe et je
pense que c'était utile de rappeler
parce que sinon on a l'impression qu'on
va aller chez les autres et que les
autres vous pourrez pas dire chez nous
ce qui n'est pas le cas ouais j'ai été
un peu longue mais je crois que j'ai
j'ai découvert avant de bois merci
madame la ministre avant de passer la
parole à nos collègues juste deux
commentaires par rapport à vos réponses
ladislas poniatowski a parlé d' urgence
mois j'insisterai encore un peu plus sur
ce point une urgence à double niveau une
urgence au niveau communautaire
on sait bien que le conseil du 18 aura
du mal être conclusive c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne 19
bon donc il y aura un autre parait-il en
juillet on aimerait avoir un petit peu
la date mais une urgence au niveau
national si vous voulez parce que la
crise est là et l'objet du plan de
relance c'est précisément pour éviter la
fragmentation de l'économie du marché
unique
or je vois que nos amis allemands eux
avec la puissance de feu qui est la leur
et le dynamisme qui est le leur
et bien je sens les je dirais distorsion
déjà s'opérer donc je vois bien combien
l'allemagne au travers des aides d'état
a immédiatement obtenu le maximum de
choses à bruxelles et je vois bien
également que sur un certain nombre de
points notamment sur la transition
énergétique et
l'hydrogène et la 5g ils vont beaucoup
plus vite que nous donc il ya une double
urgence européenne mais également
nationale et puis si vous voulez vous
avez bien dit à juste titre que les
régions seront toujours autorité de
gestion sur les fonds de cohésion sur le
fond de transition juste sur l'irak
yu ça veut dire donc si la france qui
logiquement devrait récupérer à peu près
10 4%
je dirais de l' enveloppe qui nous sera
non à allouer se dire à peu près 30 2
milliards c'est sur cette somme là que
la part dont l'état sera directement je
dirais distributrice et gestionnaires de
ces 32 2 milliards et donc j'aimerais
bien que les parlements et là dessus et
sur les ressources propres
puisqu'il faudra un vote sur les
ressources propres il soit plus
étroitement associés voilà les deux
remarques je me suis permis de vous
faire très importante remarque qui font
d'ailleurs écho avec le fait aussi que
le au parlement européen a dans ce
calendrier un grand rôle à jouer parce
que il ya des choses qui passeront et
parlements nationaux vous l'avez dit
mais il faut que le parlement européen
sur les modalités notamment des
programmes européens concret qu'on
entende d'ajuster puisse se prononcer
vous dites il y aura un conseil en
juillet si l'info de on offre à deux
s'il en faut trois on offre à 3 on a une
obligation de résultat et on voit bien
que vu les calendriers décision
collectif
si on veut que tout fonctionne dès la
fin de l'année 2020 pour les programmes
d'urgence et dès le 1er janvier 2021
pour le budget européen est la plus
grosse partie de ce fonds de relance
il faut qu'on accélère et donc ce qui
est très important vraiment à
communiquer autour de vous de vous dire
c'est pas une négociation comme on
connaît d'habitude élections européennes
le temps aujourd'hui tout le monde a
conscience que c'est un élément crucial
de notre succès est ce qu'on va mettre
dans l'accord mais aussi le moment où on
est capable d'avoir un accord est donc
on travaille en ce sens effectivement
moi je suis toujours comme vous savez à
l'ap la disposition du parlement et
bruno le maire également évidemment sur
les questions financières pour détailler
tout ce qui doit l'être sur la cohérence
françaises et européennes ce qu'on fait
merci madame la ministre
olivier cadix pour 4 minutes puis
ensuite ce sera j'arrive le comte et
andré gattolin merci monsieur le
président donc oui le 10 juin la
présidente de la commission a cité des
cas directement comme une source d
information sur les sujets liés aux
cures navires us
donc il semble que au niveau de l'union
européenne c'est vraiment la première
fois on avait l'habitude effectivement
de d'entendre parler de la russie dans
ce domaine je voudrais savoir est-ce que
lors du conseil européen vous allez
reprendre enfin revenir sur cette
question là qui est une préoccupation
qui émergent pour beaucoup de pays
européens c'est justement l'action de la
chine
et on a eu à subir nous comme
parlementaire des agressions venant du
site de l'ambassade de chine en france
lance massador lui même dont qui a pris
qui a eu des des positions très dures à
notre endroit et je n'ai pas vu que nous
ayons obtenu que ceux ci soient
modifiées sur le site ou qu'ils y soient
revenus donc c'est toujours sur leur
site on jouait savoir si lors du conseil
européen ce sujet va être évoquée dans
quelques jours ça va faire 4 ans donc le
référendum sur le bric site s'est tenue
au royaume uni et comme l'a dit le
président disait on peut comprendre de
ce fait une forme de lassitude au bout
d'un moment pour notre négociateur mais
vous avez ouvertement jugé dans un
quotidien allemand qu'il fallait se
préparer par précaution à l'échec des
pourparlers
je veux savoir ce que vous entendez par
là et que veut dire dans votre esprit se
préparer à l'échec pour les citoyens et
pour les entreprises depuis le début du
référendum
quand le référendum a eu lieu et pendant
la campagne j'avais dit que je ne
comprenais pas comment cela pouvait se
passer
pour éviter le retour d'une frontière en
irlande et nous sommes à quelques jours
je pense de ce qui pourrait être la
décision qu'on n'ira pas au delà du 31
décembre
et je voudrais savoir ou est ce qu'on en
est de la mise en oeuvre du protocole
nord irlandais à ce jour voilà le 6 mai
2020 donc le s'est tenu le sommet
virtuel de de zagreb au cours de duquel
a été confirmé sans équivoque la
perspective européenne pour les pays des
balkans occidentaux qui semble de
nouveau entré dans la voie de l'adhésion
mais par la voix du président de la
république a été évoqué la nécessité de
réformer au préalable fonctionnement des
institutions européennes avant
d'envisager une ouverture de nouveaux
membres et vous parie donc exigé un
nouveau mécanisme de négociation qu'il
soit mis en place afin de remplacer le
système actuel jugée trop bureaucratique
combien de temps d'après vous prendre à
la réforme de l'union européenne est ce
que la france a fixé un objectif en
terme de temps pour cette réforme parce
que en fait pour nous qui sommes comme
vous le savez parlementaire nous
adressons à des vrais gens et donc c'est
ce que disait jean monnet le l'union
européenne s'est pas de coaliser les
états c'est de l'unir des hommes et donc
je voudrais savoir ce que je dois
répondre aux gens qui me posent la
question puisque les serbes par exemple
attendre depuis dix ans pour eux je leur
dis c'est quand la perspective
maintenant je remercie merci olivier
cadic j'arrive le conte la ministre oui
je voudrais un peu compléter d'ailleurs
l'intervention de l'e10 peut nier tout
ce qui sur la question de la liberté de
circulation vous posons précisément la
question des étudiants qui est non
communautaires qui souhaite arriver
en europe pour ainsi que le début de
l'année prochaine et qui aujourd'hui ne
sont même pas en mesure de faire des
demandes de visa je voudrais aussi aller
dans le sens de jean bizet parce que
lorsque nous constate finalement avec le
relâchement des contrôles sur les aides
d'état sur un certain nombre de secteurs
et compte tenu de ce que fait en
particulier l'allemagne ou la france en
comparaison nous devrons nous constatons
que notre industrie automobile avait pas
attendu la crise du coc vite pour être
malade et par conséquent avec le
décalage des aides allemandes et des
aides françaises
on peut craindre le pire finalement et
on peut aussi craindre que final que que
tout ce qui s'est fait depuis quelques
mois mettent un point d'inflexion une
espèce de convergence des politiques de
deux industriels pour faire en sorte que
la comble à la concurrence soit libre et
non faussée dans l'union européenne
avec finalement une plus grande liberté
des états à aider leur propre secteur je
crois que ça c'est un point qui doit
être une préoccupation majeure alors que
nous devons essayer de faire en sorte
que ce soit finalement organisé avec à
chaque fois comme objectif la sobriété
énergétique et la neutralité carbone
deuxièmement cette crise n'a pas été une
crise européenne a finalement depuis le
début de ce débat on a l'impression que
seule l'europe a été en crise et
malheureusement cette crise est mondiale
et elle sera encore mondial longtemps et
est plus que jamais je crois que la
lâcheté au plan international on la perd
à très fort si on ne se consomme ne
regarde pas ce qui ce qui se passe
autour de nous il ya eu d'autres
souffrances que le coc vide au cours des
derniers mois et est par conséquent que
ce soit en libye que ce soit d'entrée
notre relation avec la turquie
que ce soit au ca aide que ce soit aussi
moi je trouve particulièrement paradoxal
que ce soit des parlementaires
israéliens aujourd'hui qu'ils
demandaient l'union européenne de se
mobiliser sur le risque que la coalition
israélienne fait porter sur le processus
de paix européen ça montre à quel point
notre politique étrangère européenne est
faible pour ne pas dire inexistantes
alors qu' il ya encore des gens qui
attendent de nous qu'on soit conforme à
nos valeurs et nous ne devons pas être
simplement concentrer sur nos propres
problèmes et aussi parce que nous devons
pas être concentrés sur nos propres
problèmes
sinon nous en aurons d'autres la
question qu'olivier posait sur la
question de l'élargissement oui à un
processus nouveau qui a été mis en place
de ce processus nouveau de négociations
qui étaient mis en place et qui prévoit
des bénéfices progressif pour les les
états candidats dès lors que des étapes
de négociation sur moi qu'ils aient il a
aussi besoin d'être financés par le
cadre financier pluriannuel et je ne
vois pas où c'est prévu alors beaucoup
de critiques ont été donnés sur le plan
de la nouvelle commission le nouveau
plan de la commission européenne c'est
vrai que quand on parle de carlos le
convoi après le plan franco allemand et
qu'on voit finalement ce qui est proposé
on ne peut qu'être favorablement
impressionné surtout que cette chose
qu'on attendait depuis longtemps
une fois qu'on a dit ça il ya quand même
quelques critiques apportées ou quelques
quelques remarques d'abord vous avez
parlé d'un moment hamiltonien c'est à
dire en fait d'un début d'union
budgétaire et fiscale oui mais pour le
faire il faut que l'opération soit
pérenne que ce soit pas un one shot
or finalement quand on constate qu'un
jeune de la génération qu'ovide dont le
premier emploi sur le chômage et qui a
60 ans continuera à payer les emprunts
convient de
qu'on va prendre on a envie de dire à
madame dindar et n ok boomer parce que
c'est pas du tout comme ça que nous
arriverons à créer une dynamique pour
réellement aller dans la direction de
l'union budgétaire et fiscale il faut
vraiment trouver des outils qui
pérennise cette évolution et on peut
aussi être un peu inquiet sur les
ressources propres envisagées alors
inquiet si on considère que ça sera par
des contributions nationales plus
importante
on voit déjà comment s'était dit chico
bien c'était difficile de négocier un
cadre financier pluriannuel
et si par contre ce sont des nouvelles
ressources propres si ces deux nouvelles
ressources propres qui sont construites
sur la compétitivité des entreprises ou
qu'ils taxent finalement la consommation
ça risque d'être compliqué je crois
qu'il faut absolument se poser la
question de la taxation du capital au
niveau de l'union européenne
si nous ne nous posons très sérieux on
arrête j'arrive le compte là sinon sinon
nous pas quand même quand on aborde ce
sujet on peut quand même si nous ne
pouvons pas cette question
il ya quand même une difficulté majeure
pour crédibiliser l'opération mise en
place et en conclusion je dirais qu'il
est absolument indispensable madame la
ministre que vous nous disiez un peu
comment les parlements nationaux qui ont
encore la souveraineté budgétaire et
fiscale pourront participer à cette
conférence sur l'avenir paul robbe qui
sera aussi décisive pour pérenniser et
réfléchir à la pérennisation du
dispositif mis en place
merci jean yves leconte andré gattolin
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues mâles
moins qu'on puisse dire aujourd'hui
quand même c'est que l'union européenne
nous surprend et pour une fois il s'agit
pas d'une surprise plein d'amertume
amertume à l'endroit des occasions
manquées et de la capacité à dépasser
certains dogmes trop rigide qu'elle
s'était au fil du temps imposées comme
des mantras ou des psalmodies il en faut
pour toutes les religions sans inflexion
devoir répéter à l'envi dans toute
situation
non l'union européenne aujourd'hui nous
surprend positivement en mettant de côté
plusieurs de ses tablettes de la loi si
souvent décriée en effet rompu imaginé
il ya encore quatre mois
en pleine torpeur post break cité en
plein doute existe
en ciel sur l'union l'avenir de l'union
que cette union serait en quelques
semaines capable un de suspendre la
fameuse règle des 3% de déficit public
autorisée 2 de suspendre les sacro
sainte règle limitant les aides d'état
ou trois encore qu'elle soit capable
d'envisager un plan de relance post
crise ambitieux de quelques 750
milliards d'euros financée par
l'endettement durable de l'institution à
ce propos rappelons quand même que nous
ne sommes qu'au début du processus
d'adoption de ce paquet global cadre
pluriannuel financiers et plan de
relance 2008 150 milliards d'euros
proposé par la commission en mai alors
le conseil européen qui se tiendra le 19
juin prochain ne sera en effet que la
première étape d'une négociation qui
s'annonce longue et ardue sur ce paquet
sans précédent et comme l'a rappelé la
ministre
largement impulsée par un couple
franco-allemand retrouver le conseil de
la semaine prochaine ne sera prêt
semblablement comme premier tour de
chauffe simple débat d'orientation entre
dirigeants européens car il semble selon
quelques informations que la présidence
allemande à venir envisage pas moins de
deux nouvelles réunions durant le mois
prochain afin d'espérer parvenir fin
juillet un accord sur une boîte de
négociation à ce stade madame la
ministre doute s'était rappelée par
notre collègue ladislas doute plane
notamment sur le calendrier de mise en
oeuvre de ce plan de relance qui
pourrait opérationnelle des débuts 2021
devrait être discutée et approuvée avant
et au plus tard en décembre alors le
parlement européen disposera en outre
d'un délai extrêmement court pour donner
son approbation
on parle notamment d'une validation mois
de septembre ces décisions devraient
également et ratifié très vite par la
plupart des parlements nationaux des
pays membres avant la fin de l'année ce
qui rend le calendrier plus qu'étroits
si l'on considère par le passé et à mont
noble connaissance qu'aucune décision de
cet ampleur n'a été ratifiée dans un
délai inférieur à 13 mois
madame la ministre etes-vous
raisonnablement optimiste
ce sujet car le temps presse et si nous
voulons notamment que ce plan soit
efficace pour l'europe il faudra éviter
que 2021 se solde par une année blanche
de consommation de dépenses en termes
budgétaires dans le cadre de cette
indispensable plan alors au delà du
cadre et un calendrier
les blocages risquent surtout de venir
ça a déjà été dit de la part des pays
frugaux connaissant plutôt bien les pays
d'europe du nord on va être dans
présidents des groupes d'amitié
je pense que certains d'entre eux comme
le danemark ou la suède pourrait
finalement se montrer assez rapidement
raisonnable mais s'il est certain que
les pays bas resteront très fermes sur
leur position car ils sont notoirement
contraire au principe de l'emprunt a
fortiori dans le but de financer des
subventions en espèces à hauteur de 500
milliards d'euros et des prêts à hauteur
de 250 milliards
la france est elle prête madame la
ministre a accepté un compromis sur ces
montants comme contrepartie d'un feu
vert néerlandais les résistances sont à
prévoir également à propos du
remboursement de ces prêts dont les
modalités et les conditions restent à ce
stade très flou si des pistes concernant
de nouvelles ressources propres sont
régulièrement évoqués aucune discussion
n'a à ce jour abouti sur des
propositions législatives concrètes
quelle piste l'an france entente elle
appuyé en matière de nouvelles
ressources propres et pouvez vous madame
la ministre vous confirmer que
l'allemagne insisterait sur des délais
de remboursement plus courts que ceux
assez lointain actuellement envisagée
c'est d'ailleurs 2028 à 2058 comment le
gouvernement entend t-il rassuré les
états membres qui craignent que ces
lignes budgétaires d'urgence ne se
répercute in fine et sur les budgets
nationaux à travers un réhaussement des
contributions nationales notamment des
pays contributeurs nets et enfin pour
terminer
savez vous madame la ministre parce que
je n'ai trouvé nulle part si une date
limite pour la suspension du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance est prévu ou
envisagé à ce stade on c'est évident
pour l'année 2020
c'est pas très clair pour l'année 2000
21 notamment quand on voit les
prévisions
de la commission sur une reprise de 6,3
pour cent du pib en 2021
personne n'est capable de me dire
comment on a calculé ce chiffre c'est un
signe qui permettrait de dire attention
on a lâché les rênes en 2020 sur les
déficits publics
attention de même 21 il va falloir très
vite redresser la situation et c'est
d'être à la fois synthétique pour
préserver votre temps est à la fois vous
apporter un élément clair monsieur le
sénateur qu'annick alors sur la
désinformation
je pense qu'il ya vous vous sentez vous
voyez un consensus croissant entre les
vingt-sept sur l'importance de renforcer
nos outils face à la désinformation
d'où qu'elle provienne et les
institutions européennes vous l'avez vu
sous tout à fait explicites sur la
provenance de la désinformation
on le voit que c'est d'autant plus
important dans une période comme
aujourd'hui où nous avons
potentiellement des impacts sur la santé
et sur la santé publique de cette
désinformation et donc effectivement
hier la commission européenne a publié
les propositions pour renforcer l'action
européenne dans ce domaine
cela lui avait été demandé par les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement le 20 mars
dernier la france
vous savez soutient pleinement ses
efforts derrière le président avait
proposé que nous crions une agence
européenne de la démocratie avec
l'objectif affiché de nous protéger
contre des ingérences extérieures dans
les processus politiques ou dans des
périodes de crise comme nous voyons
aujourd'hui vous savez aussi qu'on est
extrêmement mobilisés au parlement
européen sur notamment le contenu sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment terroriste
et donc si nous semble être extrêmement
important que dans une époque de réseaux
sociaux parfois envahissant nous
puissions ne pas mettre en danger la vie
des citoyens
quant à la chine je tiens à dire ici
vous le savez l'ambassadeur a été
plusieurs fois convoqué par jean yves le
drian pour apporter des clarifications
et donc je pense que notre vigilance est
très grande
là aussi sur le rôle de chacun dans une
démocratie
est ce que chacun donc est amené à tenir
comme composition qu'est ce que ça veut
dire se préparer à l'échec des
pourparlers
ça veut dire que je crois que vous en
avez bien conscient ici puisque encore
la semaine dernière j'étais devant vous
dans l'hémicycle a présenté une demande
d'habilitation dans le cas d'un projet
de loi qui est donc été adopté
finalement cmp mais semaine dernière
pour traiter tous les sujets qui sont
non couverts par l'accord de retrait qui
serait le seul accord liant l'union
européenne et le royaume uni en cas d'un
accord commercial où il avait vu ses on
a parlé de sujets liés à la circulation
des personnes et des marchandises et que
tu laisses la manche
on a parlé des droits des citoyens on
n'a pas la protection des assurés les
épargnants voilà le type de choses
ensuite je tiens aussi à le dire et j'ai
la chance et l'opportunité de vous le
redire même si nous avons un accord
commercial
la situation pour les entreprises ne
sera pas la même qu'aujourd'hui et elle
sera à fortiori encore plus différente
n'avons pas d'accord commercial mais je
rappelle un accord commercial sans
tarifs sans quota ce qui est l'objectif
poursuivi par les britanniques ce n'est
pas une situation sans contrôle ensuite
la nature et contrôler leur intensité
la manière de les effectuer dépendent
accord commercial mais je pense qu'il
est extrêmement important que nous
fassions bien comprendre entreprises que
même si nous avons un accord la
situation sera différente aujourd'hui
notamment sur les procédures de contrôle
aux frontières
on travaille la plus grande fluidité par
définition mais quand on sort du marché
intérieur
et bien il ya des contrôles ensuite la
nature la fréquence dépendra de l'accord
commercial
on trouvera plus largement vous allez à
tanger sur le protocole nord irlandais
je crois que michel barnier le dit le
redis la france est à temps plein
soutien sur le sujet nous ne pouvons pas
imaginer de signer de nouveaux accords
si les accords précédents ne sont pas
pleinement appliqué le protocole lorient
n'est conservée marchandises concerne
les aides d'état quand ça la politique
agricole est navrant de deux choses à la
fois précise et technique
il ya des questions de aussi de capacité
de la commission et les européens à
pouvoir observer sur le terrain que les
engagements pris sont tenus et donc nous
sommes extrêmement attentifs mais je
veux aussi rappeler je sais que c'est
une préoccupation vous avez ici très
fortement que nous avons la même vision
sur la partie concerne les droits des
citoyens européens au royaume uni et
bien sûr il se fait un britannique en
france les engagements pris sont de
l'ordre du droit international
c'est un traité qui engage chacun et
donc vous imaginez bien que signé un
accord commercial sa demande à la
confiance et donc la confiance ça se
gagne
et donc ça se gagne avec des actes
concrets et donc on est vigilants sur ce
sujet et est très claire sur
l'élargissement et je rejoins aussi la
question de du sénateur lecomte
l'élargissant c'est quand j'ai un sa
dépendent des pays qui sont engagés dans
ce processus
les choses sont par la nouvelle
méthodologie par la mythologie qui en
fait a été celle jusqu'à maintenant mais
qui est d'autant plus clarifier
maintenant nous devons poser un nouveau
cadre sur la table un pays qui fait des
réformes et qu'il ait fait vite a
effectivement accès à des politiques
européennes de manière plus rapide il ya
13 milliards d'euros pour l'instrument
de préadhésion dans le budget européen
je pense qu'avec 13 milliards d'euros
sur la période qui vient et vu les
enjeux on a de quoi financer beaucoup de
choses donc choses utiles pratiques
visibles et donc on a bien sûr ça c'est
dans ces fp on a également des outils
budgétaires à nos dispositions nombreux
vous l'avez vu d'ailleurs pendant cette
crise sanitaire on a pu mobiliser
beaucoup de choses notamment pour les
balkans occidentaux en soutien à la fois
logistiques pratiques budgétaires donc
l'élargissement c'est quand j'ai ça
dépend pas de moi
ça dépend du rythme de réformes sur le
terrain et donc l'engagement concret à
la fois des populations de leurs
gouvernements dans cette convergence qui
ne peut pas qu'est une convergence
juridique comment ça se construit dans
tous les domaines économiques
universitaires bien sûr l'état de droit
et donc il ya d'un côté un plein
engagement à jouer le jeu de manière
extrêmement voyez ouverte est clair et
donc c'est un match qu'on joue à deux et
donc voilà c'est comme ça que je pense
qu'il faut qu'on aille voir les choses
monsieur certains le compte sur les
aides d'état et la fragmentation du
marché intérieur
c'est évidemment pour ça qu'on a plus
que jamais besoin d'un plan de relance
européen
parce que si on laisse les états et
c'est ça rejoint la question de ladislas
poniatowski au départ si on essaie état
avec leur point de départ qui sont très
différents les uns des autres
parce que la situation au départ en
terme de chômage en termes d'endettement
en termes de pib et de croissance
n'était pas la même et donc évidemment
quand vous êtes un pays qui est un point
de départ pour des raisons dit
c'est pas forcément parce qu'au départ
réussi ou pas réussi vous réforme et
pour les raisons on le sait
d'accumulation ensemble de choses on a
besoin effectivement de lutter contre
cette fragmentation en ayant ce plan de
relance européen solidaire en messieurs
je crois qu'on en a longuement parlé
c'est intéressant de questions sur est
ce qu'on n'a pas oublié pendant ce temps
là la libye la turquie sahel ou encore
la situation en israël
je tiens à vous le dire à table du
conseil des ministres et sans en
dévoiler la nature des échanges nous
avons toutes les semaines
également eu des échanges sur ce qui se
passait en dehors de nos frontières nous
avons savez travailler extrêmement
attentivement avec le président de l'onu
avec jean yves le drian
d'ailleurs assure vous savez depuis
quelques jours la présidence du conseil
de sécurité venus sur la manière dont
nous avons au niveau multilatéral a
regardé avec beaucoup de lucidité ces
crises pour ce qu'elle était avant la
crise sanitaire mais pour aussi les ce
que cette crise sanitaire ajouté à la
crise dans la crise et donc sur la libye
vous savez il ya eu encore il ya
quelques jours avec jean yves le drian
une déclaration très forte de ce qu'on
appelle le groupe 5 + 5 pour que les
efforts diplomatiques puisse reprendre
sur le sujet turcs notamment des eaux
territoriales jean yves le drian s'est
encore rendu a eu des échanges avec les
égyptiens
bien sûr j'ai eu moi même encore la
semaine dernière dans un format m 7
avec tous les pays donc de la
méditerranée européen un engagement très
fort a en plus très grande vigilance sur
le respect de la souveraineté
territoriale d'un pays comme chypre ou
comme la grèce sur le sahel
vous l'avez vu une ministériel soutien
pour préparer soi de nouakchott début
juillet à la demande et à la suite du
sommet de peau sur cette coalition pour
le sahel et enfin sur israël je tiens à
dire ici très clairement nous voyons
avec beaucoup d'inquiétude ce que
certains voient comme étant à processus
irrémédiable d'annexion cela mettrait
serait une violation très forte au droit
international et notre engagement sur le
sujet et jean yves le drian est très
clair et très fort là aussi c'est pas
forcément visible pour le grand public
mais je tiens vraiment à vous rassurer
sur le fait que la diplomatie française
par la voix du président la république
par la voix de jean yves le drian était
totalement mobilisé sur ces crises et
sur donc la meilleure manière
par le multilatéralisme par la
diplomatie aussi par la fermeté je crois
que ce qui s'est passé au sahel avec la
neutralisation du leader d'aqmi encore
il ya quelques jours montre bien qu'on
n'a pas mis en pause
notre engagement pour la sécurité des
français et des européens
monsieur le satin gattolin bon sur
l'équilibré général de l'accord
effectivement aujourd'hui parler
beaucoup de points à discuter a peut
être paramétré
maintenant je vous ai aussi parlé de
lignes rouges des points qui étaient
pour nous extrêmement important les
subventions le fait qu' on doit pouvoir
aussi préparé l'avenir investir
massivement ne pas avoir un beau plan de
relance et un budget amoindri peut pas
faire des changes entre les deux sinon
c'est priver le court terme et se
remettent en fragilité à à moyen ou long
terme
je vous ai parlé des ressources propres
et par des rabais donc on a
effectivement un accord à trouver sur un
paquet général effectivement les
contributions nationales
il faut et vous l'avez étaient plusieurs
à souligner être vigilant parce que si
on travaille pas sur la partie des
ressources tout ce plan va être ensuite
devoir être absorbé par des
contributions à ça c'est pourquoi notre
combat sur les ressources propres il est
fondamental et je vais revenir sur les
questions de sénateurs rap sur le pacte
de stabilité là où c'est très clair
bruno le maire a dit déjà dit plusieurs
fois
nous demandons sa suspension 2021 on a
trop vu en 2009
à quel point c'était une erreur alors
que le mouvement est à la relance de
vouloir par des décisions de ce type
en fait ça vient un contretemps dans les
ford par cohérence
si nous disons que nous devons et bien
effectué une relance cohérente
européenne justement éviter une
fragmentation où chacun joue sa marge de
manoeuvre
évidemment nous demandons que ce qui a
prévalu en 2020 puissent également être
le cas en 2021
je vais répondre conjointement aux
questions du sénateur hommes et non vie
les airs ap un bon sur nos marges de
manoeuvre pour convaincre les frigos je
pense que la clé et c'est ce que on
s'attelle à faire et ce que je vais
faire ce soir en autriche et et lundi
aux pays bas il faut qu'on rentre dans
le détail il faut qu'on sorte des débats
dogmatique théorique un peu
stratosphérique parfois moreau qui sont
des comptes
on est pour ça en termes génériques
aujourd'hui je pense que quand je les
dis leur syndicat leurs entreprises sont
favorables à ce plan pour des raisons de
réalisme de pragmatisme
ils ont des clients des fournisseurs
l'autriche est un exemple majeur
l'autriche ne va pas bien si l'italie ne
va pas bien et l'italie aujourd'hui un
système de prêt ne correspond pas en
fait à la réalité de la relance que nous
devons mettre en oeuvre
puisqu'un système de prennent c'est lui
dire aux pays endettés vous est trouvé
par vous mêmes les moyens d'une relance
qui ne peut fonctionner à strict
l'échelle nationale parce que notre
marché intérieur
j'ai fait un mot qu'on n'aime pas
beaucoup en france mais notre marché
intérieur c'est la réalité d'un espace
économique de 400 millions d'habitants
soit on en prend conscience on a fait
une force soit on se dit mentalement que
il faut pas regarder spread est comme ça
et dans ce cas là ça devient une
fragilité
parce que ça va regarder les bandes ans
deviendra une fragilité donc je pense
qu'il ya des choses vont aller très
précise qu'il faut qu'on comprenne sur
le type notamment de cohérence avec les
réformes il ya débat sur le semestre
européen
on n'est pas de la création d'une
tutelle ou d'une troïka
mais il ya des choses je pense à faire
pour que chacun puisse sereinement voir
que c'est dans son intérêt et dans
l'intérêt collectif d'avancé alors sur
les chiffres monsieur ça n'aura pas
juste que vous ayez en tête le niveau de
complexité et encore de détails de
paramètres qui sont plus ou moins les
détails mais qui de paramètres à ajuster
pour que je puisse vous donner
d'un côté le chiffre de combien
reviendra exactement la france et je
tiens à dire que les milliards vont
parler ils ne peuvent s'apprécier que si
on regarde ce que le fait que la
croissance européenne dans son ensemble
repartent apportera la france et c'est
beaucoup plus que les miens on n'en ont
pas mais typiquement cela contributions
nationales les paramètres encore à
définir pour que nous puissions vous
donner le chiffre de combien en moyenne
la france aura contribué entre 2021 et
ça va dépendre du déflateur un caniveau
le fixe donc des facteurs d'inflation
ça va dépendre de toutes les
flexibilités interne au budget européen
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas définies ça
va dépendre des pensées administrative
qui aujourd'hui reste largement débat ça
va dépendre de la ressource tva sur
lesquels vous savez il ya plusieurs
façons de l'organiser et qui change pas
mal la donne ça va dépendre des frais de
collecte de douane là aussi encore à des
paramètres et donc
on a des fourchettes mais chaque
décision sur tous ces éléments et clé
est par ailleurs ce que nous arriverons
à obtenir et à faire sur les ressources
propres et avec le calendrier plus ce
sera selon l'année de mise en oeuvre de
la ressource ets de la ressource
plastique du mécanisme d'inclusion
carbone
le prélèvement sur recettes sera lui
aussi directement impactés donc on a
effectivement des fourchettes
on a des scénarios très clair sur ce que
chaque paramètre dont je viens de vous
parler vous édition nombreux change pour
nous france pays qui contribua largement
vous savez à cet effort est européen et
je tiens à le dire ici si on est dans
une logique de juste retour on est de de
comptabilité à l'euro près on ne
comprend pas ce qu'est l'europe
madame merkel dit souvent il n'y a pas
d' allemagne forte dans une europe
faible l'allemagne aujourd'hui elle a
beaucoup de moyens
c'est pas le débat mais elle ne
redémarrera pas si ses clients et ses
fournisseurs ne redémarre pas et donc de
ce qu'ont compris les frigos les
secondes et je crois que c'est beaucoup
c'est ça qu'on est en train de faire
entrer dans les têtes c'est aussi pour
ça d'ailleurs que l'allemagne a bougé
parce que cette interdépendance c'est
une force une force qu'il faut renforcer
surtout quand elle est impacté par une
crise
madame la sénatrice jouve pour conclure
sur la sur la pac jusqu'à vous dire que
et je voudrais vous rassurer parce qu'on
a quand même beaucoup travaillé et
d'ailleurs beaucoup avec votre soutien
et je tiens vraiment à vous remercier de
votre constance d'engagement vous le
savez pour moi c'est un sujet qui est
très important et qui est partagé par
l'ensemble du gouvernement comme étant
un pin souveraineté notre crédibilité
moi je dis souvent aucune puissance au
monde n'imagine est une puissance si l
import sa nourriture
c'est partir du moment où vous apportez
votre nourriture indépendant et donc
vous êtes potentiellement plus fragiles
en euros courants
on a + 4 % sur
les enveloppe totale de la pac par
rapport à 2014 2020 dans la proposition
qu'a fait aujourd'hui la commission on a
+ 3 % sur les paiements directs + 6 %
sur le feader donc le 2e pilier et pour
la france c'est plus 5% en euros
courants globalement ça veut dire qu'il
ya pas de baisse de la pac c'est que
c'est un scénario que nous avons
beaucoup combattu en euros courants en
euros touchés en euros sonnants et
trébuchants
la proposition qu'aujourd'hui la
commission nous fait ce n'est pas un
scénario de baisse je tiens aussi très
fermement
parfois sans de données ne sont pas vus
comme tête
donc l'enjeu c'est qu'on maintienne ce
niveau et est donc vous imaginez bien
que notamment on a une vie jean ce parti
gras sur le premier pilier pour que dans
les négociations des jours à venir des
semaines à venir
eh bien ces chiffres que je viens de
vous donner qui me sens extrêmement
important d'appui s'être maintenu et je
pense qu'on a plus largement et vous
l'avez dit monsieur brice dans bizet une
réflexion à avoir sur la manière dont
ces montants sont pleinement efficace
perçues par les agriculteurs comme un
soutien à l'investissement un soutien à
la transition
un vrai soutien à à leur capacité de
faire bien leur métier et donc ça c'est
pour ça vous savez qu'on a aussi une
réforme des instruments la pac dans les
tuyaux pour qu'on en fasse une politique
qui soit une politique à la hauteur des
besoins
voilà pour ce débat sur le rôle de
l'union européenne pour sortir de la
crise
notez que le président français emmanuel
macron va défendre dans les prochaines
semaines la construction d'une
indépendance européenne en matière
d'industrie c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi
continuer à vous informer sur cette
crise sanitaire et économique sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr je vous
souhaite une très bonne journée sur
public sénat
[Musique]